yearbooks
yes i found mine they're time capsules
of your clubs your friends your awkward
teenaged years it's a glimpse at high
school life well one local teacher was
recently honored for making yearbooks
her high school
life this is the first one carol metcalf
is a storyteller i'm looking for one of
my favorites for nearly 30 years she
helped tell the stories of her students
wow
1995. until recently
these were
my editors medcalf was yearbook advisor
at las vegas academy it was a wonderful
school where i was so happy to be around
such great kids another year we have one
book
oh this is it another look back at the
faces the clubs
the creativity when it became two
thousand so the book half of it's one
way and half of it's the other
intentionally intentionally but don't
ever do it
don't ever do it metcalf spent 27 years
putting their stories on the page
working long hours on days off with
their students crafting crazy ideas and
making them reality i was there to
oversee it but the kids made it happen
but what about her own story he has one
and i'm using it right now darling okay
her friend judy allen helped tell that
the biggest joy for me has been working
with carol all these years while medcalf
taught at lba allen worked for yearbook
publisher jostens i want every kid when
they turn the page to suck air and go
last week the picture was at clark
county commission chambers for those who
don't know i was the editor-in-chief of
my yearbook lva grad and commissioner
michael naft honored metcalf and allen
for national yearbook week she misses
your book i do she does i'm a
cheerleader for it as for her own
yearbook it would be a compilation of
all the good that i remember but it
would probably be the stick
[Laughter]
she was showing me all the yearbooks at
lva and there was some that were like
like an encyclopedia and others were a
little more slender these yes these are
mine i went home to my parents house and
got from my yeah from silverado high
school
that is really cool and the two of uh
judy and carol they freely admit they're
like thickest thieves they became best
friends in fact they're out of town
right now they're in ohio you know
stirring up trouble they're having a
good time so
it was great that she got honored there
and you know we always remember our
yearbooks right i think we do
i won't tell you your book staff did you
guys speaking of which oh my
god oh my god
look i look like i did
you have an agent a few years ago
you guys
what year in high school was that for
you john that was my
junior year okay that's my 10th grade
year yeah oh my goodness
little baby
pictures
while you're waking up this morning if
you've got your yearbook lying around
send it to us we'd love to see them but
yeah yeah yeah
they're archived somewhere in the vault
called my garage
those heavy stones are hard to see yes
they are they just chiseled away they
chiseled everybody's picture